สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ
ครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 11
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันศุกร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 10 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
6 โมง
โมงเช้าหรือว่า 6 โมงเย็น
6 โมงเช้าค่ะ
6 โมงเช้า 6 โมงกี่นาทีคะครูฟ้า 50 นาที
6 โมง 50 นาทีอีก 10 นาที
อีก 10 นาทีก็จะ 7 โมงเช้าแล้วแล้วครูฟ้า
กินอาหารเช้าหรือยังคะเพราะว่าตอนนี้ 6
โมง 50 แล้ว
ครูฟ้า
กินอาหารเช้า
แล้วหรือยังเหรอคะ
เออใช่ค่ะครูฟ้ากินเดี๋ยว
แค่กินอาหารเช้าหรือยังเนี่ยครูฟ้าก็ต้อง
คิดหรอคะว่า
กินหรือยังนะหรือยังไม่ได้กินเพราะว่าครู
ฟ้ายังไม่ได้กินอาหารเช้าไง
อ๋อแล้วปกติทุกๆวันวันจันทร์วันอังคารวัน
พุธวันพฤหัสบดีวันศุกร์วันเสาร์วัน
อาทิตย์ทุกวันเนี่ยครูฟ้ากินอาหารเช้าไหม
กินค่ะ
กินอะไรคะปกติอาหารเช้าของครูฟ้า
รู้ค่ะแต่ว่ากินอะไรคะอาหารเช้ามันกิน
เข้าไปไม่ได้ค่ะมันต้องเป็นอาหารค่ะ
ขนมปังค่ะคุณหญิง
คนไทยเรียก
ภาษาไทยหรอครูฟ้ากินขนมปังแล้วก็ทาอะไรคะ
พีนัทบัตเตอร์เนยถั่ว
นะคะ
เป็นบอกว่าผมดิฉันเรียนภาษาไทยฟ้าไม่ต้อง
พูดภาษาอังกฤษ
ก็
มีพีนัท Butter ด้วยนะคะหรือว่าบางทีก็
ไข่ดาว
หรอ
ใช่ค่ะ
[เพลง]
กินไข่อันนี้คือไข่ดาวใช่มั้ย
ชอบกินไข่เหมือนกันแต่เนี่ยไข่ดาว
คือเขาเป็นคนวาดรูปอ่ะนะคะนักเรียนผู้
หญิงเนี่ยคนธรรมดา
ไม่กินไข่ดาวค่ะครูฟ้าตอนเช้าๆเนี่ยผู้
หญิงไม่กินไข่ดาว
ถ้าครูหญิง
ไม่กินไข่ดาวแล้วผู้หญิงกินอะไร
ครูหญิงกิน
ไข่ลวกค่ะครูฟ้า
ทำไมคุณฟ้าต้องตกใจขนาดนั้นนะคะครูหญิง
กินแบบนี้เลยนะเนี่ยมีไข่แล้วก็มีซีอิ๊ว
แล้วก็ตรงนี้โรยพริกไทยอันนี้น่าจะเป็น
พริกไทย
นะคะพริกไทยพริกไทยพริกไทยคุณฟ้าจะไม่
เห็นนะคะนี่นี่คือไข่ลวกค่ะ
ใช่ถ้านักเรียนนักเรียนก็จะมีอันนี้ไหม
มีอันนี้วางอยู่แล้วก็จะมีไข่
ไข่มันจะสีอะไรประมาณนี้ไหม
แล้วก็จะมีไข่
อย่างเงี้ย
ต้องมีมีฐานด้วยป่ะ
อาหารตอนเช้าไงนักเรียนก็จะมีที่ใส่แบบ
นี้แล้วก็จะมีไข่ลวกเนี่ยวางแล้วนักเรียน
ก็จะมีช้อน
แล้วก็
ที่ไข่ลวกไหมไม่รู้อ่ะดูในซีรีย์มานะคะ
อืมอันนี้ไข่ลวกครูหญิงจะกินตอนเช้าๆ
ทุกวัน
ให้ลูกอร่อยมากน่ากลัวชอบนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะแต่ผู้หญิงได้กินไข่ลวกวันละ 2 ฟอง
นะคะครูฟ้าไม่ได้กิน 1 ฟองนะ 2 ฟองเลยหรอ
ได้โอเคไข่มีโปรตีน
แต่เนี่ยในชามนี้มีแค่ 1 ฟองแต่ผู้หญิง
เนี่ยกินวันละ 2 ฟองผู้หญิงกินกับซอสไหม
ใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าผู้หญิงกินกับซอสแบบนี้เลย
เนี่ย
มีซอสไงซีอิ๊ว
ผู้หญิงกินแบบว่าใช้ช้อนตักไหมหรือว่ากิน
แบบนั้นน่ะอันนั้น the  rock ใช่ไหมนัก
เรียนต้องเอาไข่ลวกเนี่ยใส่แก้วนะคะใส่
แก้วแบบนี้แล้วก็
ดื่มแต่คุณหญิงมีช้อนค่ะมีช้อนแล้วก็ใช้
ช้อนเนี่ยตักตักกินไม่ได้ยกซดแบบนี้แล้ว
ครูฟ้าล่ะเวลาครูฟ้ากินไข่ลวกครูฟ้ากิน
ยังไงยกหรือว่าใช้ช้อนตักกินมาใช้ช้อนนะ
คะนักเรียนว่าจะมีช้อนใช่ไหมแล้วมันก็ตัด
ไข่ลวกนิดหน่อยแล้วก็กินแล้วก็ตัดนิด
หน่อยแล้วก็กินแต่ว่าครูฟ้าใช้ช้อนที่
เป็นช้อนเล็กๆอ่ะหรอ
ช้อนแบบกาแฟนะ
ไม่ได้นะคะผู้หญิงก็คือใช้ช้อนแบบใหญ่ๆ
เลย
ต้องช้อนใหญ่ๆ
[เพลง]
กินนิดหน่อยอร่อยกว่าค่ะ
อันนี้คือไข่ลวกนะคะนักเรียนไข่ลวกเนี่ย
ไข่เนี่ยมันไม่ได้สุก
100% ใช่ไหมไม่ได้สุกส่วนใหญ่แล้วเวลาทำ
ไข่ลวกอันนี้คือไข่เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงขอภาพไป
ที่ไข่ลวกก่อนนะคะนักเรียนนี่ไข่ลวกใช่
ไหมเขาก็จะต้องต้มน้ำเนาะต้มน้ำให้เดือด
100 องศาเซลเซียสนะคะแล้วก็ค่อยเอาไข่ลง
ไปคิดว่าเอาไข่ลงไปลวกประมาณเท่าไหร่ 5
นาทีไหม
5 นาทีเลยหรอ
ส่งป่ะไม่ถึง 5 นาทีค่ะ
น่าจะประมาณ 2 ถึง
มองไม่เห็นนะคะที่เปลี่ยนสีอยู่เนี่ย 2
ถึง 3 นาที
ใช่ไหมแล้วก็เอาขึ้นอันนี้คือไข่ลวกนะคะ
แต่ว่าก่อนที่จะไปพูดถึงเมนูไข่เนี่ยนะคะ
นักเรียนคือเวลานักเรียนมาประเทศไทยนะคะ
คือไข่เนี่ยส่วนใหญ่ที่คนไทยกินเนี่ยมัน
ก็จะมาจากสัตว์ 2 อย่างก็คือไก่ใช่ไหมมี
ไก่แล้วก็เป็ดนะคะอันนี้คือเป็ดก้าบนะคะ
ถ้านักเรียนมาประเทศไทยนะคะแล้วนักเรียน
ไป Supermarket แล้วเห็นไข่ที่เป็นสีขาว
อ่ะที่เปลือกไข่สีขาวเนี่ยในประเทศไทยนะ
คะ
100 โอ้
พอจะเอาสีอะไร 100%
ไข่เป็ดนะนักเรียน
ใช่ถ้านักเรียนมาแล้วก็ให้ไป Super แล้ว
ก็เห็นว่าไข่เนี่ยเปลือกไข่สีขาวก็คือไข่
เป็ดไข่เป็ดใช่ค่ะถ้าไข่ไก่ก็ต้องเปลือก
ไข่สีไข่ไก่
สีออกเนี่ย
น้ำตาลส้มๆน้ำตาลส้มๆแบบนี้ถ้านักเรียน
ไม่กินไข่เป็ดใช่ไหมนักเรียนกินแค่ไข่ไก่
นักเรียนก็ต้องซื้อไข่ที่สีแบบนี้นะคะอัน
นี้ถึงจะเป็นไข่ไก่เพราะว่าบางประเทศอ่ะ
ไข่ไก่สีขาวก็มีเปลือกไข่
แล้วก็จะมีไข่แดงแต่คนไทยเรียกไข่แดงนะ
ถึงมันจะสีสีเหลืองก็เหอะเนี่ยไข่แดงนะคะ
อันนี้คือไข่แดง
คือใส่ไข่แดงของไข่เป็ดถ้าเป็นไข่เป็ดใช่
ไหมอันนี้จะเป็นไข่ไก่นะคะแต่ถ้าเป็นไข่
เป็ดไซส์เท่ากัน
ไข่แดงมันจะใหญ่มากอ่ะ
ๆแต่มันอร่อยนะ
ใช่บางคนชอบไข่เป็ดไงคะแต่คนไทยผู้หญิง
ไม่ชอบกินไข่เป็ดไงก็เลยคิดทำไมอเมริกามี
ไข่เป็ดเยอะจังแต่พออ่านไข่ไก่นี่นาทำไม
เปลือกไข่สีขาว
ของประเทศไทยเป็นไข่เป็ดแน่นอนนะคะให้นัก
เรียน
ไข่ไก่เนี่ยก็เอามาทำไข่ลวกได้นะเอามาทำ
ไข่ลวกได้แล้วแต่คนชอบใช่ไหมแต่ว่าเมนู
ไข่เนี่ยนะคะมันไม่ได้มีแค่ไข่ลวกไง
มีอะไรอีกอะไรถ้าเราต้มน้ำให้เดือดแล้ว
เอาไข่ลงไปลวกเนี่ย 2-3 นาทีก็คือไข่ลวก
แต่ถ้าเราต้มน้ำเอาน้ำใส่หม้อแล้วก็เอา
ไข่ใส่ลงไปแล้วก็ต้มๆๆน่าจะประมาณ 7 ถึง
10 นาทีเนาะ
7-10 นาทีอ่ะมันก็จะเป็นอะไร
มันก็คือไข่ต้มนะคะเห็นไหมไข่แดงมันจะไม่
เหมือนกันไหมอันนี้คือไข่แดงเนี่ยสุก 100%
นะคะไข่แดงเนี่ยสุกอันนี้ไข่ต้มครูฟ้าชอบ
กินมั้ยอ่ะไข่ต้มอ่ะชอบกินไข่ต้มมากคือ
แบบชอบ
กินไข่ค่ะ
ครูฟ้าชอบไข่แดงสุก 100% เลยไหม
มันไม่ชอบไข่แดงสุก 100% อาจจะซัก 80
80% ใช่ไหมถ้าครูฟ้าชอบไข่แดงสุก 80%
เนี่ยครูฟ้าอาจจะต้มประมาณซัก 5 ถึง 7
นาทีพอ
สมัยถ้าสมมุติว่าครูฟ้ามีตู้เย็นนะนี่อัน
นี้เป็นตู้เย็นนะคะนักเรียนเวลาเราเปิด
ออกมาใช่ไหมตรงนี้ก็จะมีไข่ไข่ไข่อันนี้
ก็อาจจะมีขวดน้ำมีแครอทมีบล็อกโคลี่มี
ฟรีเซอร์เนี่ยตู้เย็นถ้าใครอยู่ในตู้เย็น
ครูฟ้าก็ต้องต้มประมาณ 7 นาทีนะ
ใช่เพราะว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยต้มไข่ทุกวันค่ะ
ครูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงก็กินไข่ต้มกินไข่ลวกบ้างนะคะก็
ไข่ต้มอย่างนี้แต่ถ้าไข่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่
ได้อยู่ในตู้เย็นครูฟ้าก็ต้มประมาณ 5
นาที
ไข่แดงเนี่ยมันจะสุกประมาณ 80% ใช่ไหมที่
ครูฟ้าชอบนะคะแต่ถ้าเราเต้นนานๆอันนี้สุก
100% ไงก็แล้วแต่นะคะแต่ใครเนี่ยมันก็
ไม่ได้มีแค่ไข่ลวกไข่ต้มนะคะนี่มันยังมี
ครูฟ้ากินไม่
ได้ค่ะไข่ดาวใช่ไหมไข่ดาวเนี่ยครูฟ้าชอบ
ไข่แดงสุกหรือว่าแบบนี้ไข่แดงไม่สุกในรูป
นี้นะคะคือไข่แดงไม่สุก
สัก 95%
ใช่คือครูหญิงชอบแบบนี้
สมมติแบบที่ 1 แบบที่ 2 แบบที่ 3 แล้วก็
อันนี้แบบที่ 4 แบบนี้ครูหญิงก็ไม่ชอบนะ
ไข่แดงไข่แดงเนี่ยสุกแบบประมาณ
10% ไหม
แบบที่ 4 เนี่ยอันนี้ครูหญิงก็ไม่ค่อยชอบ
นะคะผู้หญิงชอบประมาณแบบที่ 3
มันชอบแบบพี่ส่ง
ไข่ดาวที่ไข่แดงเนี่ยสุก
ซึ่งไข่ดาวเนี่ยเราไม่ได้ต้มเนาะเวลาที่
เราทำไข่ดาวนะคะเราเนี่ย
นักเรียนแล้วก็เปิดแก๊ส
ตอกไข่ลงไปแล้วก็ทองทอด
นะคะใช่ซึ่งนักเรียนคะนักเรียนอาจจะทอด
ไข่ดาวในกระทะแบบว่าเป็นกระทะอะไรนะกระทะ
เชฟรอนใช่ไหม
ที่ไม่มีน้ำมันเพราะว่าอันนี้คือน้ำมันนะ
คะแต่นักเรียนดูคนไทยทอดไข่ดาวสิคะดูคน
ไทยใส่น้ำมันน้ำมันเยอะมากนะอันนี้น้ำมัน
อันนี้ทอดไข่ดาวได้ 2 ลูกเลยนะจริงๆ
[เพลง]
ไข่ดาวทอดที่ใส่น้ำมันเยอะๆนะคะคนไทยปกติ
นะไม่ใช่คนไทย Healthy นะคะ
มันอร่อยกว่าไง
ไข่ดาวนะคะเพราะว่าไข่นักเรียนอาจจะกิน
ไข่ดาวแล้วก็มีซอสเสร็จแล้วเหมือนไข่ต้ม
แต่คนไทยกินไข่ดาวกับอะไรก็ได้นะคะต้มยำ
กุ้งอาหารเผ็ดๆก็กินคู่กับไข่ดาวได้ใช่
อุ๊ยพูดแล้วคุณพ่อก็อยากกินไข่ดาวนะคะ
เนี่ย
ใช่มั้ยคิดว่าอาหารที่คนไทยกินกับไข่ดาว
มากๆก็คือผัดกะเพรา
ผัดกระเพรานักเรียนรู้จักหรือเปล่าผัด
กะเพราเป็นอาหารที่คนไทยกินนะคะเยอะมาก
เพราะว่าเวลานักเรียนมาประเทศไทยนะคะอัน
นี้ผัดกระเพรา
ผัดกระเพราไข่ดาวนะคะเวลานักเรียนมา
ประเทศไทยแล้วกินผัดกระเพราเนี่ยเขาอาจจะ
ถามคนขายเนี่ยเขาอาจจะมีคำถามถามนักเรียน
ว่าเอาไข่ดาวไหมไข่ดาวแบบไหนสมัยนักเรียน
ก็ต้องบอกว่าใครแดงไม่สุกหรือว่าแบบครู
ฟ้าใช่ไหมแบบที่ 1 แบบที่ 2 ไข่แดงสุกเขา
อาจจะถามนักเรียนก็ได้นะคะ
ชอบมากนะคะคิดว่าชอบมากที่สุดเลยใช่ไหม
ใช่
อันนี้คือไข่เจียว
เนี่ยนะคะนักเรียนครูฟ้าเนี่ยกินได้
365 วันใช่ไหม
ให้
รักมากนะคะใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าชอบแล้วเวลาครูฟ้า
กินไข่เจียวเนี่ยครูฟ้ากินกับซอสไหม
ไม่
เหมือนเหมือนผู้หญิงนะคือบางคนชอบกินไข่
เจียวกับซอสนะ
แต่เราไม่ชอบค่ะเราไข่เจียวโอรี่
แล้วครูหญิงเนี่ยก็ชอบไข่เจียวแบบนี้นะคะ
แบบที่นักเรียนเห็นเนี่ยผู้หญิงไม่ชอบไข่
เจียวแบบใหญ่ๆอ่ะ
คนไทยเรียกว่าไข่เจียวฟูหรอ
ไม่ใช่ปูนะคะ
ปู
ผู้หญิงหาให้ดูนะผู้หญิงไม่ได้เอารูปเออ
ไม่ใช่อาจจะไม่ใช่ไข่เจียวฟูมั้ง
ที่ไข่เจียวมันจะเป็นแบบนี้ครูฟ้าไม่รู้
ครูฟ้าเห็นหรือเปล่านะคะชอบมาก
ผู้หญิงไม่ชอบเลยไม่ชอบเลยผู้หญิงเข้าไข่
เจียวแบบนี้ที่นักเรียนเห็นอันนี้สำหรับ
ผู้หญิงคือดีที่สุด The  Best นะคะนัก
เรียนถ้าใครทำอร่อยอร่อยมากนะผู้หญิงทำ
ไม่ค่อยอร่อยนะคะอยู่ที่ไฟด้วยแหละ
ผู้หญิงไม่ชอบนะคะแต่ว่าอร่อยเหมือนกัน
เนาะคือไข่เจียวเนี่ยเวลาที่เราทำไข่
เจียวแล้วก็ต้องเอาไข่ใช่ไหมตอกไข่ใส่ชาม
ใส่อะไรก็ได้นะคะแล้วก็เอาส้อมแล้วก็ตี
ใช่ไหมตีไข่นะคะแล้วก็ใส่ซอสใส่ซีอิ๊วใส่
อะไรก็ได้ที่นักเรียนชอบนะคะแล้วก็เอาไป
ทอดไข่เจียวก็คือการทอดแบบน้ำ
อันนี้คือไฟดีมากกระทะดีมากนะคะตรงนี้มัน
จะมีไฟใช่ไหมนักเรียนเวลาเราทำไข่เจียว
เนี่ยมันก็จะต้องมีไฟใช่ไหมไฟ
ถ้าเราทอดแบบนี้ก็คือน้ำมันเนี่ยน้ำมัน
เนี่ยร้อนพอดีนะคะโอ้อันนี้อร่อยนะคะแล้ว
ก็มีอีก 1 ไข่นะคะที่ผู้หญิงคิดว่านัก
เรียนบางคนอาจจะไม่รู้จักไม่เคยเห็นไม่
เคยกิน
ไข่ลูกเขยเมนูนี้เนี่ยชื่อว่าไข่ลูกเขยนะ
คะก็จะมีมีไข่อันนี้ใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็มีซอส
เงี้ยซอสผู้หญิงบอกไว้ก่อนเลยนะคะว่าซอส
เนี่ยหวานมากนะน้ำตาลน่ะน้ำตาลน่าจะ
80% นะคะอ่าหวานๆเปรี้ยวๆ
หวานแล้วก็เปรี้ยวนะคะแต่หวานแต่ผู้หญิง
ชอบนะไข่ลูกเขยอ่ะครูฟ้าไม่ชอบกินหวานแต่
ครูฟ้าชอบกินไข่ลูกเขยนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะแล้วไข่ลูกเขยนะคะนักเรียนมันก็คือ
การที่เราเอาไข่ต้มนะไข่เนี่ยที่ต้มต้ม
แล้วเนี่ยนะคะไข่ต้มเอาไข่ต้มไปทอดเหมือน
รวมกันน่ะ
เพราะว่า
ไข่เจียวเนี่ยทอดใช่ไหมคะหรือว่าไข่ดาว
เนาะไข่ดาวเนี่ยไข่ดาวก็ทอดไข่ลวกไข่ต้ม
นะคะแต่ไข่ลูกเขยเนี่ยก็คือเอาไข่ต้มไข่
ที่ต้มเอาไปทอดนะในน้ำมันแบบนี้ใช่เอาไป
ทอดทอดนะคะแล้วก็ทำซอสเนาะนั่นแหละค่ะก็
เป็นเมนูไข่ลูกเขยนะคะสมัยนี้มีไข่ลูกเขย
ไข่เจียว
ไข่ดาวไข่ดาว
ไข่อะไรคะ
ไข่ลูกอ้วก
ไข่ต้ม
ไข่ต้มเก่งมากแล้วก็สุดท้ายก็คืออยากจะ
เมานิดหน่อยนะคะผู้หญิงเปิด
ไข่ลวกนักเรียนชอบไข่อะไรมากที่สุดก็
คอมเมนต์บอกเราได้นะคะครูฟ้าชอบใครเจียว
นะคะผู้หญิงเนี่ยชอบไข่ลวกมากที่สุดใช่
กับไข่ต้มนะคะแต่ว่านักเรียนชอบเมนูไข่
เมนูไหนแล้วก็ชอบใครเป็ดหรือว่าใครไกลก็
คอมเมนต์บอกเราได้นะคะส่วนวิดีโอนี้ผู้
หญิงกับครูฟ้าไปก่อนเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้า
สวัสดีค่ะ